well you found the video just for you
how do you get opengl working on mingw
it's why is it so complicated well uh uh
I'm gonna it took me longer than I
expected and when I finally figured it
out it was so so stupidly simple that I
was annoyed that I spent like four hours
trying to figure it out when it took me
like two minutes really and I'm gonna go
over why it's so darn complicated and
what you actually need to know okay so
men GW compiler its minimalist a new
compiler for Windows that way if you're
using if you already using Linux just
you know you have probably already have
the compiler if you have a new GCC oh
yeah this is also gonna be geared
towards C and C++ compiling so OpenGL
so you you want to get mingw you just go
to the downloads on their page gonna
take you to release thing I think use
this get thing it does a little
installer and you basically want to get
this IMing GW setup install it once you
have it set up it's gonna be on your
root directory so you'll see it like
like here so you drive help you see all
this stuff inside it that's what you
need to know all right so you got that
leave that open for a minute we'll get
back to in a second so we'll assume you
got mingw set up on your Windows machine
close it out so you next you need OpenGL
naturally you think okay I'm just gonna
search OpenGL find the top hit of the
actual site and use that well there's a
big problem with this that's kind of
obscure the main version from from
actual the actual developer OpenGL
hasn't been updated since I don't know
like the Ice Age you don't necessarily
know that cuz you can go download the
old one supposedly it just doesn't work
right and all the documentation on it's
super old doesn't didn't seem to work
when I tried it nothing added up I was
just like what this is like anyway so
free glut you want free glut if you're
doing OpenGL this is what you want very
confusing use the one that's actually
supported anyway if you go here free
glut sourceforge.net takes you to this
page you'll see the stable releases
you'll see the prepackaged releases here
we go here's the easy way you want this
one
packaged one for mingw let's keep this
simple no need to make this really damn
complicated and you get to this page and
you'll see see it right here
free what for em mingw
so you download that sweet you get this
you get this package I've already
downloaded this guess I'll do it again
and we're gonna isolate it just just to
show you explicitly so free glut mingw
thing that you download there is I'm
using P zip you can use whatever
unpacker you want to use right-click
we're gonna extract here on your folder
just unzip it on package you got
together so unpackage it open it up
you'll see a bin including a live
remember this a little mingw this on the
root of your drive this one from
installing it will you just take these
and you let them combine in so you drag
them in down here so that it combines
with the other folders you know it's
been and they're gonna merge together
include clue they're gonna merge
together you can copy them over however
you decide to do I've already done this
so I'm gonna click skip like you'll just
let it go the first time and all the
file will go in these for example so now
there'll be a free ball tol so somewhere
in here yeah and so on and so on for
these other folders so basically now
mingw has all the stuff or free glide
ready to go so now you can you can open
your your editor maybe you're doing this
through command line or something that's
fine too I'm using sea lion and under
her the build execution deployment tool
chains
I have min-gu selected and it's using
sea make free 10 to latest one isn't
this time and that's pulling it from
this from this reef tribe to mingw
hope I'm not over explaining but trying
to try to make this thorough so now that
that's all set up we can closed if you
want or whatever and there we go
no now you want to you want to make some
files and link it okay
so on your C make most of this Moses
just gonna be the same let's let's take
it from the top sort of you want to
basically you'll do a new project C++
executable do create it creates you a
main dot CPP and C make list of text the
cement your see Michael is on text at
the bottom you need to have target
linked libraries of course the name of
your project is this so it might be
different lines OpenGL test these are
your files that you're compiling and
your linker commands so this is these
are the main things in the linker
commands tell OpenGL 32 l free glut so
there there you go it's running and
literally all I did was put that stuff
in that directory and link it correctly
and okay these files already get these
files good question good question you
look at my downloads real quick so I
found
Ricola 3.0 and I unpackaged it
unpackaged it again and in here there
was Prague's and demos and all these
demos have code that you can just use to
test up out so what you can literally do
to test this you can take one of the
keys that's the one I was doing I'm
gonna take a simpler one like fractals
fractals there's a dot there's a C file
fractals so I'm gonna open it up I've
got a notepad it looks ugly because it
doesn't understand line endings are they
ever gonna fix that it's like it's 2018
and notepad still doesn't understand
line endings anyway let's open it with
something else so that actually looks
like it makes sense so when I would
Jeannie so this is just a big main
basically well
they have a whole set up to do what they
intended somewhere in here there's a
main that use with all these functions
yeah yeah you got a cyclists elect all
copy and select all on this main and
just overwrite it with this free glut
3.0 frogs I got this from those Prague's
are on the stable release try out those
demos that are here they need this one
here to actually set it up with mingw
this one here has all those demo
Prague's if you want to mess around with
those start learning and there you go
there's there's how you get opengl
running using free glut and GW you're on
linux code should be the same the linker
commands are probably the same it should
be the same okay I think that'll do it
thanks for watching my video I hope you
learned a little something here and
there and get your hello world on OpenGL
running and you're set you're off to
profiting in the world until next time
peace out this has been Matt from code
tech and tutorials please subscribe if
you are interested in this kind of stuff
don't forget to give this video nice big
old like and it helps support my channel
a lot alright see you around don't
forget to leave a comment - to say
something you know something it helps me
so much I'm just kind of winging it half
the time I know what I'm doing or do it